le président français emmanuel macron
est attendu ici au palais présidentiel
ukrainien vers 12h30 heure locale ici à
qui est ce la fait 11h30 à paris au menu
une heure et demie de discussions avec
son homologue ukrainien volodimir
zelensky suivie d'une conférence de
presse conjointe et d'un déjeuner de
travail sur la table la discussion qui a
eu lieu hier entre emmanuel macron et
vladimir poutine à moscou avec plusieurs
points à discuter notamment le statut du
donbass et l'avancement du protocole de
minsk avec un objectif pour le président
français avancer de manière concrète il
y à une réunion au format normandie dans
deux jours et beaucoup de questions sur
la table avec beaucoup de pression au
niveau politique intérieure pour le
président céline ce qui par ailleurs il
ya également le statut de l'ukraine plus
largement en matière de traités de
défense européen ici dans la capitale
cette visite est très attendu on se
félicite de l'initiative française même
si de nombreux observateurs ukrainiens
avance qu'il aurait préféré voir
emmanuel macron passé par kiev avant
d'aller à moscou l'ambiance en ville est
finalement assez normal même si dans les
médias de nombreux sujets tournent
autour de la manière d'évacuer le pays
en cas d'invasion ou encore de
préparation de la population à des
activités militaires en ville